[Music]
there's talk that the Postal Service
might be out of business by Christmas
now I don't want you to worry but the
Postal Service is working very hard
right now to appeal to the younger
generation here's their latest ad hey
kids what are you up to found this whole
thing on the corner thought it'd be fun
to smash it and then we're gonna go home
and play video games on our internet
devices what if I told you this old
thing was actually a magical gateway to
the coolest funnest place in the galaxy
come on I'll show you know you're in the
post office where you can find all kinds
of cool fresh stuff for teams like
padded envelopes cardboard tubes and
computers you can send your best buds
real-life text messages email you can
touch
and we have something no teenager can
resist Garfield stamps so be sure to
visit your local post office we're going
hip-hop honest open fly place to use to
send out cool stuff it doesn't have to
be there in a hurry the United States
Postal Service
[Music]
[Applause]